[Music]
hey everybody its charlie there was a
new promo for Avengers 4 that posted
recently to Reddit that everyone asked
me to do a video for so I'm gonna
explain what's going on because there
are a lot of questions about it so no
worries I'm doing a new round of the
giveaway for that infinity war art book
that has all those cool alternate
costumes and ideas that they ended up
getting rid of before the final cut of
the film all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comments on the video so
starting with number 5 if you have no
idea what's going on there's a new promo
that posted or leaked to Reddit
depending on how you feel about it it
shows all the Avengers in the newest
additions like nebula and rocket wearing
special upgraded white suits with little
hand pieces on top of their hands
naturally a lot of people have
assumptions about what's going on with
this there's a lot of confusion for is
it real or is it fake so big question
going around the fandom today there's a
couple of reasons why I think this is
early concept art that is real but
important to remember the role of
concept art in the early development
phase of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers 4 remember the video that I
just did about spider-man's black suit
during infinity war or the alternate
ending of the movie all early versions
of the film that changed later on so if
someone asked you if spider-man ever had
a black costume during infinity war he
never wore one during the movie that we
saw in theaters but he did have a black
costume at one point there's also a
couple of earlier pieces of evidence
that we've gotten to suggest that this
picture is real so 3 the white costumes
that we saw in the toy art from last
month I did a whole big video about it
because it shows Thor and Rocket wearing
white costumes that look almost exactly
like this presumably that's being
developed by a toy company because this
is literally a screen cap of the back of
a toy box which is means that somebody
had to make this they had to print it
and they have to be developing it to
ship out next year before Avengers 4
comes out which takes a lot of work toys
can take up to a year to develop and
manufacture before a movie comes out
Disney makes about 10 times as much
money on toy sales for Marvel movies and
for Star Wars movies than it does on the
actual films themselves toys are huge
for them in order to drive toy sales
they have to be different looking
characters that to be the reason for you
to buy a new Thor toy if you already own
one it can't be the exact same design
which is part of the reason why
characters like he and Iron Man gets so
many different costume changes they need
to sell more toys it's really cool to
see Thor gets Stormbreaker
it's a really badass moment and it's
important for the narrative but it's
also a critical piece in the puzzle that
allows them to sell more toys and make
way more money early on in the
development phase for movies the concept
artists that work on all the Marvel
movies there's like a group of them they
just work on every single Marvel movie
the directors like the Russos will go to
them give them their ideas for what the
film could be the concept artist will
come up with designs a bunch of
different versions of designs the
directors will pick the ones that they
like and then they'll move forward with
those the visual development department
is a very small team of artists that
have worked at Marvel Studios almost the
entire time at Marvel Studios has
existed it was created in 2010 Kevin
Feige Ludi Esposito and Victoria Lonzo
they saw that it would be beneficial to
create an in-house art team sometimes
the filmmakers use this as sort of like
a test ground to see if something that
they're thinking of would look cool what
we call keyframe illustrations
administration that summarizes a scene I
do a lot of action sequences get the
energy in those comics flash pages it's
very difficult to create that sense of
detail it's a same deal with toy sales
the concept designers come up with early
ideas give those through the toy
companies almost a year in advance so
that the toy companies will be able to
ship those toys on time before the movie
premieres but what you wind up with is
is that over the course of the
development of the movie things change a
lot so that's how you have designs for
infinity war like Spider Man in his
black costume that get thrown out really
early on because they were developed at
the very beginning of the process so
just because this concept art might be
real doesn't mean that these white suits
will wind up in the movie that we
actually see when we sit down to watch
Avengers for spider-man did not end up
wearing that black suit but it does
confirm that the Russos were probably
thinking about putting them all in
matching suits at one point during the
film either for a sequence or just for a
brief second sometimes it's a really
brief moment usually those are the
things that get thrown out first like if
it's not really important for the film
then it's not absolutely necessary - a
lot of people are assuming that these
are meant to be the Avengers quantum
realm suits or just their quantum suits
if you want to refer to him that way
enabling them to harness quantum energy
or potentially survive inside the
quantum realm that's not confirmed that
that's what they're actually for but
they all have little devices on their
hands that look a lot like the wrist
devices that Iron Man Captain America
and ant-man are wearing and all these
behind-the-scenes pictures from Avengers
4 seems very suspicious just another bit
of evidence as to what these suits might
be for there's not enough evidence to
say what the plot is going to be but
they do a lot of foreshadowing between
doctor Strange's 1 and 14 million
reality where they beat Thanos and the
ant-man in the wasp post-credit scene
where Janet Van Dyne says collect these
healing quantum particles that will help
the ghosts from phase shifting between
different universes randomly and watch
out for time vortices which are
apparently all over the place inside the
quantum realm because he could wind up
getting sucked into a different time
period without any warning the quantum
realm is a whole other territory and a
whole other terrain that we can play
with make sure you stay out of the
TARDIS
they're cute but they'll eat you and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you
[Music]
stealing particles secured for our new
ghost friend though haha very funny
most of the Avengers probably do not
have the gear to survive quantum energy
or the quantum realm you would have to
give them a new suit so that they can
use them to travel between realities in
the quantum realm or at the very least
harness quantum energy which in the
movies they've been hyping up as the
most powerful thing ever next to the
Infinity stones you have to consider the
little bit of evidence that Kevin Feige
talked about the themes in the story
over all of Avengers 4 the Avengers
coming together to work as one learning
to be a true team what's the best way
that you show that everyone has come
together as a true cohesive squad you
put them all in new costumes that all
look the same matching uniforms usually
tells you visually that they are in
unison number one a lot of you appoint
this out it's kind of funny to most of
you immediately saw this and said why is
Iron Man wearing another white suit on
top of his bleeding-edge armor does not
make sense
why is ant-man wearing a white suit his
regular suit works just fine inside the
quantum realm and he's still wearing it
during all these behind-the-scenes
pictures that we see from Avengers 4 so
it seems like his suit survives whatever
event it is that gets him out of the
quantum realm and back with the Avengers
Thor is a God why would he need a
special suit Marvel Studios hasn't been
super clear on what the limits of
quantum energy are and how they're
different from Thor getting soaked with
the energy of an entire star while he
was forging Stormbreaker
so again putting them all in matching
white costumes I think is just concept
art for potential toys and potential
quantum realm ideas that the Russos have
regardless of what the plot actually is
it Iron Man for instance wouldn't be
wearing additional armor on top of his
bleeding edge armor his bleeding edge
armor nanites would just form around him
as a second skin to look like this the
nanites can be programmed to deploy any
kind of specialized armor or weaponry
that he wants so he wouldn't need to
have a different suit of armor he would
just have to reprogram the nanites to
whatever this winds up being so
really important let me know in the
comments this is early concept art for
Avengers 4 do you actually think that it
will survive to the final cut of the
film and even if we don't see it in the
actual movie we'll get more of this kind
of stuff when they release another art
book for Avengers 4 just like they did
recently for Avengers infinity war most
of the time you don't find out what's
real and what their alternate plans used
to be until they release these books
even though it would be fun to find out
earlier but also let me know what you
want my next Marvel video to be about in
the comments and I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post that click
here for the alternate ending to
infinity war in that different final
battle and click here for my breakdown
of all the early aquaman reviews thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]